a family is mourning the loss of a woman
who was found dead earlier this week
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock i'm sasha loftis a vigil was
held for 24 year old destiny jackson her
body was discovered in a desert area
south of las vegas sunday just a day
after she was reported missing madison
kimbrough has more on tonight's event
madison
a day of closure for jackson's family as
they all gathered near the area where
her body was found seeking justice for
an act they still can't believe happened
to one of their own
never in a million years that
we will go through something like this
to one of our kids
so many questions still unanswered as 24
year old destiny jackson's body was
found in a desert area south of las
vegas a day after she was reported
missing last weekend through social
media her friends and family knew
jackson went out but when she never
showed up to pick up her boyfriend
that's when loved ones began to worry we
do know that this wasn't by chance
she was a victim of something bigger
than what we understand
it just breaks my heart that
she
was around the wrong people on sunday
jackson's mother said she got a call
from the coroner saying that jackson's
body was found nearly a week later a
vigil was held to honor her candles
flowers and pictures lined the desert
path as family and friends gathered to
say a few words and the vigil was meant
to bring a sense of peace back to the
family if her soul is still here we're
here to take her home we came
to get closure some closure to us so
that we can
move on and move on to the next chapter
jackson's death is being investigated as
a homicide and police are still
searching for the suspect in the case
reporting live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now